hello and welcome to this video and this
blitz game okay that's too tempting I
know it's weird to say the exchange
range is tempting but I really have a
pretty good score with this so why not
yeah this is an important resources
Queen e2 that made this whole line quite
significantly more attractive for white
I have a very nice quick development and
it's not so easy for black to get this
position organized you know in a good
way so how to do this is b5 something
that I should be worried about I don't
think so I think this is a good one and
then 95 probably White's pieces are so
very active and it's not so easy if I'd
like to coordinate this what what how do
you actually get your pieces then your
pieces developed just 95m that's easiest
yeah I wonder if before um what I should
play them even 95 as a as an idea
I can go 95 yeah okay so this is the the
most normal-looking move the question is
if simply 97 and Bishop e7 is already
giving me something it is giving me
something the question is is it is it
anything significant but it's not so
easy for black to make a move taking
only five is not really an option maybe
before something okay I'm going to play
I'm just a bit of a strengthening move
and see what black is going to next
before night a form and then possibly 95
yeah
I don't have anything great it seems hmm
maybe I should have should have played
Rudy 100k I'm thinking about f4 but he's
got c5 and it doesn't really it doesn't
look that great
hmm that's it's a bit annoying let's see
five is working maybe yeah maybe I made
a mistake down no the alternative is
just to take and play 95 it's a bit may
it's a bit simplistic but it's
definitely definitely possible
[Music]
I don't think that I'm threatening
something directly would okay this is
possible Rudy okay so we should be 78
then okay you can check here though okay
so let's do it
takes rook takes that must be good for
white to say that these dad's it's more
than good probably okay King h8 is only
move under Knight f5 I don't know I
would be scared but black him that
something is getting lost looks a little
bit loose yeah but where do you go your
bishop we should be aight i mean IAM why
i can still just go be should be seven
and then takes you five yeah this is not
fun for black
no no fun I mean what else is there
Bishop b8 Bishop g7
I don't really I'm threatening d6 and
then b7 will hang immediately so there
is no intermediate move like h6 or f6 or
something like that just he has to move
the bishop
[Music]
so there's also rookie 7 that is also
pretty pretty annoying you know baby
should be 7s good dog it's it's simple
and it's strong at least as far as I can
see and it's not helping you giving me
yet another pawn
yeah I mean this is the the exchange
variation has produced so many quick
wins for me it's kind of funny
especially when I when I when I talk to
people until my hand
you know they exchange that's nothing
and so I I keep winning so many games
that's crazy
I came that's this one I will just take
the pizza this back rowing is a bit weak
ok so let's have a look there I mean
this is some pretty much a theoretical
position so this this yeah and I don't
quite know how should he untangle this
he went b5 looks natural enough 95 and
now what Bishop e7 still not heavily
criticized by the engine and from here
you have to think about what what I'm
doing if what I'm doing is fine the
engine seems to like the capture on the
7 what I did one month later and you can
I mean this is this of course I
considered but I have felt like after
rupee aid I don't have much in fact I
did not see that you know this is
actually interesting still I did not see
that I have this move but could be could
be something with the active noid but
the engine the engines evaluation is
going down just a very slight edge so
this is probably again a little bit a
little bit too simple there are ideas to
play but should be same then go a 4 or a
4 here on the other hand this is also
something that makes some sense to
instead of rook c1 make c5 more
difficult to play okay well I played
rook see one rupee aid yeah now I didn't
find anything better than taking a 95
which is what the engine also wants to
do my original intention was f4 but
after c5 I don't have a good move it
it's just I don't have anything good
down no I mean okay I have some some
sort of equality but the problem is that
this is a big check and Knight takes is
even better
according to the comp okay yeah no
that's true
I don't have anything I have no good
with him anyway
I took on d7 that is stronger 95 just
centralizing and now black has to deal
with those ideas white going to e7 so he
took on you won and now c5 that is
probably probably the mistake it's a
very understandable move here you kind
of want to get rid of that potentially
weakest pawn but it's not good
h6 is still roughly equal according to
the comp yeah I'm not sure if I would
have played Bishop d2 them now but I
kind of have to hear this this is just
not a good idea it's a self pin losing a
piece so I would have gone to d2 there's
just no other moves really okay you
can't go to H fraud this makes a bit
more sense keeping this covered and then
some work move form almost equal yeah
and c5 is probably not working check and
okay the engine actually gives this a
still kind of K ah okay okay this is
this is important to point yeah I'm not
winning a pawn here because again of the
pin so I probably should play Ruby seven
and keep that this
actor would have this active look and
then this yeah I mean okay this is
better for white but it's not you know
the winning or anything just taking a
spanner okay now that's still still
tough all right this is just lost right
yeah it's plus a million plus three you
know okay rook e8 didn't help but if you
go here and I take c5 it's just it's
just terrible and yeah you're here just
win-win-win the house I could have taken
the look I didn't see that I mean okay
if you have a luxury problem and take
absolutely everything here yet this line
with with Queen e2 and the Queen trade
is surprisingly difficult from like to
handle it's not like he's in in terribly
bad shape but it's very unattractive if
you can with what you have easy moves to
make some pressure and like is quite
often not able to cope with that thanks
a lot for watching